皆さんこんにちは、道元です。今日はスポンサー付きの動画で、
立命館アジア太平洋大学(APU)について話したいと思います。
日本九州地方の別府市にある大学です。
僕はそこで働いていたことがあり、
新しく一緒に仕事し始めたJPも最近までそこで働いていました。
これはタイアップ動画ですが、
この動画を作ろうと思った主な理由としては、
この動画でこれから話すことは
自分が高校生だったときに知りたかったことだからです。
どういうことかと言うと、
自分が高校生だった頃、日本に興味があり、
どうにか、なにかしらの形で日本で過ごしたかった。
海外留学や、長期で働くなど、
とにかく、どうにかして日本にたどり着きたかった。
そうするには、アメリカの高校から
アメリカの大学にそのまま進学して、
その4年間のうち1年は留学して、
卒業後に英語の先生として日本にまた来るしかないと思っていた。
実際そうしたんだ。その選択肢しかないと思っていたから。
ワシントン州にあるレドモンド高校からワシントン大学に進学して、
1年間、東京にある慶應義塾大学に留学し、
アメリカに帰って学位を取得し、英語の先生としてまた日本に来た。
そうするしかないと思って、そうした。
もしアメリカの高校から日本の大学に直接進学できるって知ってたら、
全く日本語を話せなかったとしても、
そういう選択肢もあると知ってたら、
絶対そうしていたと思う。
APUや、こういった別の道を提示してくれる大学に進学していたと思う。
この情報が欲しい人が少なからずいると思うので、
どうやってAPUに出願するのか、
APUがどんな感じなのか、学生生活について、
先に一つ強く言っておきたいことは、
だいたいの場合、アメリカの大学に行くよりも日本の大学に行った方が安い。
それについては後で説明しますが、
まずはキャンパス自体について話したいと思います。
APUの学生数は約6,000人で、
別府市にあり、
僕が住んでいる小さな都市なんですけど、人口は12.5-13万人で、
九州の大分県にあります。
九州は日本列島の主要4島のうち最も南西にある島です。
APUという大学自体のいいところは、
まず、結構新しいところです。
この大学は2000年に設立されて、同年4月1日に開校したと思うんですけど、
当たり前ですけど、キャンパスが建てられたのはそれ以前ですが、
僕が通ってた東京の大学に比べると
キャンパスの建物が新しく、
東京で通ってた大学はビジネス街の真ん中にあって、
キャンパスが非常に小さくて、オフィス街を歩き回っているような感覚です。
キャンパス内はそんな感じで、中庭はコンクリートで舗装されているし
でもAPUはもっと開放的で、
自分が見たことのある日本の大学と比べるとはるかに大きく、
実際キャンパスがどんな感じか見せたいのでここに映像を流しますが、
別府を見渡せる山の上に建物があり、
立派な美しいキャンパスです。
僕は昔APUで働いていて、すごく良かったのが、
お昼休みとか何かをするときに
キャンパスを歩き回るのがただただ心地良い。
環境が本当にきれいだから。
開放的で、全く窮屈でない。
まず、学校の物理的な側面から言うと、とても快適です。
そして、巨大な寮が大学の敷地内にあり、
東京や日本のほとんどの大学と比べて異なる点は、
まあ少しずつ変わってきているようですが、
東京の大学の寮に住んでいたのですが、
それは大学から30-45分ほど離れていました。
一方で、APUでは
都心部に位置する寮もあるのですが、
1年生の国際学生は全員、
山の上にある大学敷地内の寮の部屋を確保できると思います。
山のてっぺんにあるので、
ここにいくつか映像を入れますが
寮の部屋から見える景色は絶景です。
何度も言いますが、キャンパス自体とても素晴らしい場所です。
日本の他のほとんどの大学と比べると、
少なくとも自分が見てきた中では、
APUは別格です。
ですので、キャンパスについて、物理的な意味でとても良いと思います。
では、大学の目的、
在学している学生の構成と、
2つの学部と、
この大学ではどんな教育を受けられるのかという、
この動画の中身となる内容について話していきたいと思います。
APUが日本や世界中の大学と一線を画しているのは、
全学生数のうち半分は国内学生で、半分は国際学生である点です。
僕が留学していたとき
正確な数字は覚えていないんですけど、
圧倒的に日本人が多く、
大学の国際学生の多くは、
僕みたいな、大学に1年間だけ通う留学生だった。
残念ながら、こう言った状況下でよく起こるのは、
少人数の外国人のグループがあったとして、
その他の学生がみんな日本人だったら、
その狭いグループの環境から出ていくのが難しくなり
異なるグループ同士が交わりにくくなる。
くだらないと思われるかもしれませんが、
その壁を打ち破るのは結構難しいです。
実際、自分がいたキャンパスでは、食堂で少人数の国際学生のグループがいて、
その他は国内学生といった感じでした。
もちろんいくらかの交流はありましたが
もう一つ重要なのは、交換留学生のほとんどは
日本語を勉強するために留学しているので
国内学生の多くとは上手く話せず、
国内学生たちの多くは流暢な日本語のみ話すので
コミュニケーションの面でも壁があります。
これらの事情があり、
自然にこの2つのグループがそのまま出来上がってしまい、
それぞれのグループに居続けることが多いです。
APUはこれとは根本的に違っていて、
APUでは全学生数の半分、
つまり、学部生(4年間在籍する学生)の半分は国際学生です。
僕みたいなアメリカの高校を卒業したアメリカ人の学生が
直接日本の大学に進学して高等教育を受けるような形になります。
APUの学生の半数がこれに該当します。
必ずしもアメリカ人というわけではなく、世界中から来ています。
国内学生も国際学生も両方1年生からのスタートで、
そして寮で一緒に暮らします。
また、APUでは1年生のときから互いに交流しないといけないような授業が
多く用意されており、
先ほど話した壁は、アメリカだろうと日本だろうと
一般的な大学では存在しますが、APUではそれは全くありません。
本当に国内学生と国際学生を半々で交ぜた感じです。
一つ付け足したいのは、先ほど、交換留学生がグループで過ごすのを
慶應の例を挙げて話したんですけど、
僕がアメリカで通っていたワシントン大学でも
同じことが起きているのを目にしました。
何が起きるかと言うと、交換留学生が日本からやってきて、
日本人の交換留学生のグループができ、
それ以外は50-100人の日本人の学生で、
彼らはそのグループ内で話して過ごしていた。
APUはそういった面では根本的に異なり、
1年目から完全に交ざっています。
事務職員や教職員、生徒でも、
APUで出会った人、一緒に働いた人のみんなと過ごしてきた中で、
僕は良い思い出しかなかったので、
簡単にいくつかエピソードを紹介します。
当然、JPはAPUで知り合った人の一人なんだけど、
多分一番お昼を一緒に食べたのは2人いて、
名前は出しませんが、1人はケニア出身で、もう1人はウガンダ出身でした。
だから大体の場合、ケニア出身の人と、ウガンダ出身の人と、
アメリカ人の自分と、日本人の職員2人って感じで
みんなでキャンパスの食堂に行き、
そこでは国際的な料理を出していて、
ハラルフードなどの制限のある食事のオプションも様々で
そこに入っていくんですけど、
みんなで英語で話したり、完全に日本語で話したり、
2つ組み合わせて話したり
そして隣の席には
韓国人の学生、中国人の学生、そしてウズベキスタン出身の学生がいて、
みんな日本語で話していて、すごく思い出深い光景でした。
APUの魅力を示すエピソードをもうひとつ。
僕はAPUのリクルーターだったので、
東アジアや東南アジアなどアジア周辺を訪ね、
これらの国に行くとき、説明会を企画するんですけど、
毎回、これらの都市にいるAPUの卒業生と会い、
発表をした後に、卒業生たち5-10人と一緒に食事に行って、
自分と、中国人の人と、マレーシア人の人、ウズベキスタン人の人、
ケニアやウガンダなどのアフリカの国々から来た人など、
どこ出身であろうと、
日本ではない全く別の国で、
みんなで中華料理でも食べながら、日本語で話す。
それも特別で記憶に残っている経験ですね。
APUでの日常生活がそんな感じです。
ここまでAPUの学生の半数は国内学生で
半数は国際学生だと示しました。
これはかなり重要なポイントで、
前にAPUで仕事をしていたときに会った人々や、
過去の自分のような人々など多くの人が
海外留学プログラムを通さないと
日本の大学に申し込めないと思い込んでいる。
でも全然そんなことはないです。
国際学生がAPUに出願しやすい、
APUならではの特徴が2つあります。
1つは、APUには年に2回の入学期間を設けていることです。
日本のほとんどの大学では4月に学校が始まるのですが、
APUは2回の入学期間があるのです。
出願し、もし受かったら9月から通えて、
これは欧米の多くの高等教育の入学時期に沿うようになっている。
それか、日本の学校に通っていて既に日本に住んでいるのであれば、
4月の入学期間に出願できる。
どちらかの時期に出願できます。
もう一つすごく重要で、高校生だったらみんな
疑問に思っているであろうことは、
APUに出願するには日本語を
話せないといけないのかということ。
答えは、ノーです。
全部英語でも全部日本語でもAPUに出願できます。
片方が流暢であれば出願できます。
日本語が少しも分からなくても大丈夫です。
少し知ってたら願書に書いておけばプラスになりますが、
多くの生徒は日本語が全く話せなくてもAPUに出願し、合格しています。
高校の最終学年のときにアメリカの大学に出願するのと
同じような形でAPUに出願することができる。
APUに内申書を送り、APUになぜ通いたいのかを
記した志望理由書も送るんだけど、
それら全ての手続きを、英語でできる。
毎年APUに入学してくる国際学生の圧倒的多数は
英語で出願し、日本語はほとんど話せません。
そのあと、APUでは必修の語学の授業があり、
最初の1、2年は日本語の集中的な言語教育を受け、
国内学生も同じような流れで英語教育を受けます。
それらの授業を受けることで、国内学生と国際学生の両方とも、
お互いの言語を学び、4年間の大学生活の終わりには、
大体の場合、少なくとも会話レベル、
または日本語で就職できるくらいには習得できています。
就職についてはのちに話します。
では、費用について話しましょう。
APUで4年間または1年でも勉強するにはどれくらい
かかるのか気になっている人が多いかと思うので
費用の内訳はどんな感じなのかについて
幸い、アメリカの大学で高等教育を受けるよりもずっと安いです。
内訳を見てみましょう。
APUでの学費自体は米ドルで言うと1年につき$13,500-$14,000くらいです
通貨の為替レートによりますが。
日本は現在、できるだけ多くの国際学生を受け入れて日本で学ばせたいので、
様々な奨学金の制度があり、特にAPUに入学する国際学生向けに
奨学金を提供するものもあります。
これは個人的な話で、もちろんAPUの国際学生の全員が
奨学金をもらっているわけではありませんが、
僕がAPUで仲良くなった国際学生のほとんどは、
所定の授業料減免を受けていました。
これらは授業料の30%から100%までの間で減免されます。
例えば、50%の減免を受けるとしましょう。
そうすると、APUの学費で払うのは1年につき$7,000です。
APUは日本大分県別府市にあり、
東京などに住むのと比べるとはるかに安いです。
僕は寮に月$750払っていたんですけど、
先ほども言いましたが、その寮は慶應から離れていて
でも、別府では住むところが探しやすく、
例えば僕が住んでたアパートは、
インターネット込みで、水道光熱費は別だったけど、月に$300でした。
だから、東京で同じ広さの部屋で住むのにかかる費用の半分もしません。
また、学生寮に住むこともできます。国際学生は全員、
一年目は大学の寮で部屋が保証されています。
金額はここに載せますが、
とてもお手ごろだと思います。
全ての費用を踏まえると、つまり、生活費と、
学費と、
あとアメリカ人だったら特に嬉しいのが、健康保険料、
これらを考慮するとアメリカよりも日本の大学に行った方が相当安い。
別府は安く住めるし、
APUはアメリカの私立大学と比べれば、最初から学費は安いのに、
その上、国際学生には様々な奨学金の制度が用意されていて、
アルバイトもできます。日本語で。大学内でも、学外でも
APUにいる間、学費の足しにできます。
別府でコンビニとかに行って出会う人はAPUの学生であることが多いです。
全てを考慮に入れると、
従来の欧米の大学に行くよりも、APUに行く方が圧倒的に安いです。
ここまで、日本人でなくても高校から直接
日本の大学に行けるということと、
キャンパス自体がどんな感じか、写真なども見てきましたが、
APUでの教育はどんなものかについて話したいと思います。
特に、過去に仕事でAPUについて説明するときによく言っていたのは、
APUはあることには向いているけど、それ以外のものには向いていない。
どういうことかと言うと、
APUには2つの学部、つまり2つの教育分野があり、
一つは経営学部で、もう一つは社会科学学部
それぞれの学部にはさらに4つの専門分野があり、
ここで画面に載せますが、
例えば社会科学学部には、国際関係や観光学などの分野があり、
経営学部には、伝統的な経営の授業が受けられますが、
この2つについてAPUははすごく向いていて、
しっかりとした認証を取得していますが、
プログラムやロボット工学、英文学などでで学位を取得したければ、
APUは向いていません。
この2つの分野について興味があればふさわしい大学ですが、
他の分野ではそうではありません。
それを先に知っておいた方がいいです。
そして、すごく興味深いと感じる点は、
APUの語学ではない授業、
語学の授業とは日本語の授業みたいに言語を学ぶ授業のことで
語学の授業以外の授業で、APUでは学部生の授業の
ほとんどは日本語と英語の両方で講義が受けられます。
つまり、APUに英語で出願して、英語があなたの基準言語で、
入学するときには日本語をあまり話せなかったとしても、
日本語がある程度のレベルまで習得できたら、
普段受けている専門分野の授業
例えば、観光学の授業の観光学基礎など、
その授業を英語または日本語で受けることができる。
それも、APUと他の多くの大学が大きく異なる点だと思います。
最後に、就職について話したいと思います。
これは本当に大切なトピックだと思います。
ほとんどの人は、日本で就職して長期的に住むには、
僕がしたことをするしかないと思っている。
要するに、アメリカの大学か日本以外の大学を卒業して、
日本で英語の先生になり、
それをしながら、追い追いなにか別のスキルを習得して、
のちに翻訳家にでもなるみたいな感じで。
たくさんの人が英語の先生になりたいと思い込む。
本当は英語を教えることに情熱を抱いていないのに。
APUの良いところは、
たくさんの国際学生や
英語や別の言語を話せる国内学生がいるので、
何が起きるかと言うと、毎年何百社もの日本の企業が学生を
採用しに直接APUのキャンパスに来校するのです。
ですので、日本で仕事探しや、就職活動を
ずいぶんと簡単に進めることができる。
日本国外で住みながら日本の仕事を探すよりも。
APUにはキャリアオフィスがあり、
いろんなことを教えてくれるんです。
日本の企業に応募するときの履歴書の書き方だったり、
面接を受けるときのビジネスマナーのアドバイスなど。
企業はAPU卒の学生はその仕事に必要なスキルを
持っていると分かっているのでAPUに直接企業が来る。
いくつか例を挙げると、
ある学生は観光学を学んで、
福岡観光コンベンションビューローに就職しました。
また、ある学生は Google Japan に就職しました。
そしてもう一人の学生、過去に動画に出演した人がいるのですが、
ここでは名前は出しません
彼は日本のゲーム会社に就職しました。
だから、混乱して気が遠くなるような手続きをして、
できるだけたくさんの人に履歴書を送り、
それも自分が何をしているのかよく分からずに
先が見えない中をひたすら進む、アメリカに住むアメリカ人として
日本企業に応募する、
またはさっきみたいに英語教師の仕事を探すよりは、
APUの制度を通して、
APUは企業を直接大学に招いているので
そこから直接企業に行った方がいい。
本当は興味がない英語を教える仕事に就くよりは。
この動画で最後に強く言っておきたい点は、
APUを通して進んだら、日本に住んでいなかったら
難しいであろう日本での就職の機会を与えてくれる。
キャンパスで募集しているからAPUは特にそうなんですけど、
全学生の半分は国際学生なので、APUはこの点ではとても長けています。
いくつか数値を出してこのトピックを締めくくりたいと思います。
全体的に、就職率はとても高く、
国内の部にいて国内学生を担当していたので、
正確な数値は覚えていないのですが、
いくつか画面に載せます
何割の国際学生が日本の企業に就き、
そもそも何割が就職できたのか、
そして何割が日本国外の国で就職したのかが見れますので、
ここに載せます。
もうAPUがどんな大学か大体イメージ出来たかと思います。
この動画で一番伝えたいのは、
アメリカの、または日本以外の国の高校から直接、
日本の大学に進学して、4年間日本で過ごすのは可能で、
多くの場合、アメリカかどこかよりもずっと安く住めるし、
卒業後、というより最終学年で仕事を探すとき、
日本で幅広い様々な就職の機会が待っている
この従来とは少し異なる道を進めば。
最後に付け足したいのは、
もう既に大学に通っていて、日本国外でも国内でも、
この動画を見て、面白そう、そこに行けばよかったと
思っていただけたら、
APUには編入制度もあって、
もし既に4年制大学に在籍していたら、APUに編入して、
2年か1年分は少しはお金を節約できるかもしれない。
それに加えてこの動画で話した他のメリットもありますし。
説明したかったことはこれで以上です。
APUのホームページと連絡先のリンクは
下の概要欄に載せておきます。
この動画が誰かの役に立てられ、理解を深められたら幸いです。
また、この動画のスポンサーに
なっていただいたAPUに感謝申し上げます。
皆さん、またお会いしましょう！